hello everybody my name is nyan i'm the
black female engineer i provide content
for new
and aspiring software engineers and
today we are building
a website with html and css
so let's get right to it so this is
going to be the end result
of all our hard work just a very simple
very clean landing page
this could be for anything for your
business
for your personal brand
etc so we're going to start off by
defining the doctype the document type
and that's html
in the language english so that's
just the abbreviation en and we're going
to
add some items in the head first
the meta char set which
really character set which is utf-8
my bad then we are going to
link our css
[Music]
and so the relation
to the html is that it's a style sheet
and the href is the style
dot css that is what i named the css
file
if you named your css file kangaroo it
would be kangaroo.css
next we're going to define the title
of the page which is landing page and
we're going to do a quick smoke test
this is just to make sure everything's
linked correctly
so i'm going to change the body
background color and css to purple
and boom there it is and so we know
everything is linked
correctly
now i'm going to just fix this spacing
up a tiny bit
i like to have last face and to move the
head
indentation back and now we're getting
into
our body tag
there we go so now we're going to define
our first
div class and that's going to be top
dash banner
and we're not going to do anything with
it because it's just going to hold an
image for us and so we're going to
define our next div
class and that's going to be main dash
section
and in main that section we're going to
create another div
called section dash 2.
and so in section 2 we're actually going
to create another div because these are
our containers and so this next div
is for the photo we want to have
and we're going to keep it simple call
it left photo
and so that's that left photo we saw in
that preview and so it's not going to
hold anything but the image
so we'll get back to that and so the
next div
is going to be right text literally very
simple i like
to keep everything very simple here
and so in write dash text we're going to
define an h1
and we're going to say design a personal
website
that attracts your dream
opportunity
something you know that sounds legit
and then we're going to define an h4 as
our subheader
which is going to say our free resources
reveals
the main factors
to consider when building your personal
website
and then lastly we're going to have a
button and that's going to say
get my free booklet
so we're almost done now getting
to the next main section which is going
to be
that list we saw
and so this div class is going to be
named section
3 and in that div we're going
to have an h2 which says
what it explains inside
it's referring to the booklet we are
talking about here and then
we're going to have another div with the
class name of
lyft and within that we're going to
create
an unordered list i.e a
list of bullets and so we're going to
do our first li tag we're going to
say why building your personal website
is the best next step for your
career
the next list item we're going to say
or the the next bullet point
is going to say how to create
a personal website
and be known in your industry
for your skill sets
so that's the second bullet point the
second lift
item the third we have i think
five in total so the third
is going to say how to create
a short and long term
sorry how to create a short and long
term goals that represent
your vision
and what you want for the future
my bad that a is a typo that is my bad
i'm not
i just noticed it now
then we have the best practices for new
developers
looking to build their brand in the tech
industry
then the last bullet point the last list
item
is the top five insights
brought to you by talented developers
in your community
to ensure success
in your transition
so now i'll give you all a moment to
catch up
we did a lot so i'm going to zoom out
here
and let you all catch up you can pause
if you're all good you can fast forward
but yeah i'm gonna sit here for a hot
minute
[Music]
my
so now outside that
list div we created
but still in section 3 we're going to
create a div class named photo
zoomed in and then close it right away
because it's going to be an image we'll
grab later
and then finally we're going to create a
div
class with the name main dash section
dash button
and in this we're going to create a
button
with the text get my free booklet so the
same button we had before
just again to you know really urge them
to get this hypothetical booklet y'all
and then
we're going to create our
final div of class footer
and we're just going to add a simple
copyright statement
with the p tag with the class name
of copyright we're just going to say
example
company name you know whatever that is
and then all rights reserved
so i'm going to zoom out show you what
the second portion should look like so
feel free to pause
to double check you have everything i
also added that copyright symbol
next to example something here i just
googled it and then copy and pasted it
so you can do the same thing
but yes feel free to pause and if we
refresh
there it is beautiful
so we're going to get to the good stuff
of finally styling
all the links you'll need are in the
description box below
including this one which is the myers
reset
we need this to take away all the
default
styling that our browser implements
because as developers that can get in
the way of our styling and
we then may be wondering why is it not
showing up the way i want to etc so
you put that in there and then i just
comment
end of myers reset just to
know when my code begins
and actually there's a typo there we go
there we go and yes it's in the
description box
below and so we're going to take this
image this first image
we're going to use that for our first
div
so we're going to define just some stuff
for our body we want the font family to
be stand serif
and we want the font weight to be
lighter which basically just means it's
thin text instead of more heavy text as
i see
the myers reset did all of that
pre-styling yep it is all gone now
and so we're going to go into our first
div here
which if you recall was called top dash
banner
we're going to add that image we just
saw so we're going to say background
dash
dash image url parentheses
quotes and then paste that url in there
it's in the description box below
and so now you also want to define some
other properties
the size of it you want it to cover the
entire
div
we also want it to not repeat itself if
it can't cover the whole dip if it's too
small
what css will do is create all these
recoups we don't want any repeats
just the one image and we want it to be
fixed
which you'll see the effect of that
later creates this coral
effect while strong while scrolling the
width we want it to be 100
so cover the whole page from left to
right to cover the whole page
and then the height 600px and there it
is
so now we're going to make the position
absolute
and we're going to define the z index
now making the position absolute
and defining the z index which is
basically what order we want the dips to
appear
will show up when i define the next div
but basically it's going to make it so
that
things can overlap one another instead
of just appearing one by one
so you see how everything disappeared is
because the z index here is one
so we're saying we want this to show up
first and since nothing
else is defined then
everything else into the background so
we'll we'll see it in a second
and so it you have to stack the index
one two three
with the third div being the third thing
to be on the screen so you'll see what i
mean
in a second but with the main dash
section
class we're defining the padding dash
top the position and c index s2
so you see how once i defined the index
s2 it popped up
yep because we're saying you want this
to be the second thing
stacked
padding top makes it so that the text is
a little bit
down in the position relative makes it
so that we'll later be able to
make everything or make two specific div
side by side
so dot section two display inline block
just for that side by side effect margin
dash left we want to move
15 from the left so it's going to
actually move
to the right from the left padding dash
top you want it to be five percent so
it's going to move
down five percent
from top to down i hope that that makes
sense so we're just yeah
pushing that top five percent
now we're going to style the
class left photo div
and so that's the background image
we have the url and then the quotes
inside the parentheses
and we're going to grab this image
into the url so that
link is going to go into that url
and then we're going to do the same
thing we did last time
defining the background size saying that
we wanted to cover everything
we want the width to be 350px
it's not you know too big and then the
height
to also be 350.
so if we refresh there's our image you
see how it's on top
of the back of the other image yeah
that is what we wanted
so now we're saying float left which is
also going to
contribute to that side by side effect
you'll see of the div soon oops
there we go
and then we're going to define the
margin that's right
it's just saying hey push it to the left
from the right
35px this makes it so that the two divs
have space between each other they're
not touching
and we want the margin desktop to be 10
so move down about 10
see how there's that little tiny space
in between that next text
and the picture here that's because of
the margin dash
right and then the float left allowed it
to be side by side along with the
inline and the things we had defined
above
now the dot right text which is that
piece of text we just saw we want that
width
to be 700 px going to be a pretty big
box you want the height to be
485 px i'm very particular
with my height and then we want the
background color
to be a specific color not just you know
red or teal
but rgb that stands for red green blue
248 231
and 215. it creates this kind of tan
peachy-ish color more more tan but
with the hint of peach
now we want the color of the text
to be this like blueish color so rgb
20 66
103 so yeah this
like nice subtle blue here
then we want the padding top
to be five percent so we want the text
to be moved down about five percent
and we need the flow to left here too
because we want them both to float next
to each other
so i'll let you catch up for a second if
you need to pause here
and then we need the margin dash left
35px so let's see what that looks like
boom there's our big bot
and now we're going to style the text
inside
so for the most part what you'll see
now from this point on is going to be
things
you've now seen before things we've
talked about so it's going to be a bit
less talkative
and more just fold along
when there's something new i'll
definitely jump in here
and explain to you what that was
perfect example is actually right now
the line height
which we're sending to 60px really
determines how far away
or how long the line is
so if i comment it out you see how
the space in between each line is closer
to each other
if i put 160 px you see how there's a
huge
space between each line of text yeah
that's what the line height does
it spaces out each line of text
we're also going to redefine the font
family because
here specifically we want it to be
something different it's going to be
dash apple dash system and then what
pops up in your vs code you just click
tab that's all i ever do
and then the font weight is going to be
200 so a bit
more than the lighter font weight we had
to find
in the body tag the very first
um style we did so a bit
more weight a bit thicker than lighter
but still not as thick as the default
that was the h1 now we're doing
the dot right text so the class write
dash test which we defined
h4 and so that's how you grab certain
elements in css
if you have you know a p tag or a header
tag
inside a class you just add that
header add that p tag to the class name
so the class name and then
p or h1 etc
we're going to redefine the font family
here as well
we also want it to be the apple system
see how that looks here
and then finally we're going to style
that button we just saw
so dot write dash text the class name
and then button
[Music]
so here we're going to define the border
color
because the default is black and so we
don't want to see a black border with a
blue
background then we're going to define
the border radius
which makes it so that the edges are a
bit more curved
instead of this cut you know
right angle and then just to find the
font here
and see what that looks like
in a moment
we're also going to define the border
width
which is that you know line around
the button to one px so that it's a thin
line
rather than this thick border
then we're going to just make the letter
spacing 2px which just
makes the letters a bit further apart
from one another
so now i'm going to give you all a
moment to catch up i'm going to zoom out
and start from that end of myers reset
so here's that first half we did and
then i'll move on to the second half
[Music]
so now we're going to style the button
some more specifically
on the hover what we want the button to
do when we hover
over it so we want to change the
background color to white
and the text color to that blue so
basically invert
those colors and so i'll show you what
it's going to look like
so now if we refresh when we hover
you see how the colors invert
we also want the cursor to be a pointer
oops
to be a pointer when we hover it
to indicate that hey this is clickable
and then finally we're going to change
the transition
so you see how quickly it turns into
that new color
so you want it to be a more slow smooth
transition
so if i refresh
now you see that it's slower yeah
because we set
the transition to 0.4 seconds so we're
saying
finish their transition from the
previous color to this color
in 0.4 seconds
the bigger that number is so say one
second two seconds
the slower the transition is
so i'll demonstrate that here so if i
say 1.4
seconds you refresh you see how much
slower that
is so yeah it's a fun little
styling feature but yeah let's bring it
back to 0.4
and we're good on to section
three same old same old
[Music]
this
so
and now we're styling that bulleted list
we have
i actually liked the styling for this
you'll see
there's some little things we do that
some of you may not have seen before
[Music]
bye
so now we're going to say that we want
the list style
type to be
none so this just gets rid of
the default styling for bullet points
but then we'll add those bullet points
[Music]
back
so now styling each list
item we want the list style type
to be a circle you'll see it's a
different circle than a typical bullet
point
and then we also want the padding
left to be 1.5 em
em is a kind of a measurement
like px but em is more relative
to the font size of everything so you
can define
things with either pxen
or percent you see here i used percent a
lot i really
like that but you see how the bullets
are these hollow circles
yep that is what we wanted
and then we also want the bullet point
to be
actually a different color so we're
actually grabbing the marker itself
which is that circle we're going to make
it like a brighter orange
you know for aesthetic
and boom there it is
and now we're going to add our last
image oh actually this isn't our last
image our
last image of person
is i just called it photo zoomed in
because it's that
original picture but zoomed in and from
a different angle
and so you know the drill by now with
the background image and all
oh and actually i'm realizing
i picked the wrong image for that
first person image we have so let me
yep i picked the wrong image so let me
go up and fix that so one second while i
fix that
it's a very easy fix we're just going to
change the link we used
the url we used to be of the
right image
there we go
and now we're going to take this url
and put it down in that zoomed in
there we go
and no we can't see it yet because we
haven't defined our width and height for
it
so let's do that now
[Music]
now we're styling our second
button that appears
in that main section
everything should look familiar
so there that was the button class the
div
now we're actually grabbing the buttons
within that
div and styling
that specific component
so
[Music]
so typically you need the same styling
as before
border with one key x because you want
thin
lines and see how thin this line is
let's fix a few things let's now style
that hover
and we should be good for the button
[Music]
so
and now finally the footer
the footer is where companies will put
their copyright information
their contact information any links they
want
but ours is going to be very simple
since
you know we have none of that
we're going to make the background
image that previous image in our
in our top banner
then do everything like before
with the background styling
[Music]
let's take a look
and there it is so it creates this look
of a natural continuation
of our first image and so i just
like how that flows together
so i really like having a fixed
background so let me show you what not
having fixed looks like
you see that
so when it's fixed we're saying we don't
want the image to move
when we scroll and so it creates this
cool
effect on this hole
now you'll see that styling
truly in probably all
my apps on my sites
because i just love it so much
now we're going to do some quick styling
for the p tag which is our
copyright statement
so we're defining the pattern for the
top right
bottom and left in that order that's
what defining padding the way i just did
it
does so you don't have to keep saying
padding top or padding right
or patterning bottom and the same
applies for margin you can
apply all four statements in one going
clockwise
and all accounted for
and then the background color will make
it a more navy blue than we've been
using
a little darker
and so we're going to do this so we can
see the text that
we had put that sentence
or that notice of copyright that's why
we're
adding a background color for the p tag
and so there it is so we still wanted
that
background image but let's also make
sure we're seeing our text
so i actually want to make some edits to
our landing page
first i want the list items the very
first word in each
list to actually be bold and so we're
going to do that
by putting in the strong tag and putting
in
the word the first word of the list and
so we're going to do that
for each of the
list items
[Music]
and then we need to tell css that we
want strong to represent
bold so we're going to just put strong
just at the very end here and just say
font
weight bowl and let's space out the
letters a little bit as well so let's
do letter spacing 2px
and let's see if we refresh and there it
is
the first words are bold
now i also want to make the text just
a little bit meteor let's add just
another sentence to each
bullet point you can really add any
sentence you want
this is just for stylistic purposes
and so let's see i'll just say something
like
implementing these changes
will drastically
change your career outlook
i'm just going to copy that same
sentence onto all of them
and then we'll see what it looks like in
just a second
[Music]
and so now we're going to change a
couple things in css
first that zoomed in image
we're going to make it so that there's a
boss shadow
just to make things a little bit more
interesting
so we're going to say negative 30px so
that the shadow appears on the left
10px and 100px
big around the shadow to be and then the
color of the shadow is going to be
like a dark tan ish color
so that's rgb 209 176
so if we refresh and there it is
just to add a little bit more subtle
color
i also see that the margins are not
aligned
together between the list and the image
so we're going to say margin dash top
for that image
to be four percent so it's going to move
it down four percent
and there it is
that looks about right
now we're going to decrease the space
between
that first and second section so we're
going to change the padding top
oh and actually there's already padding
top defined i forgot
so we're going to change it from 18
percent to 13
to just decrease that size see that it's
a little smaller
just little changes can make all the
difference i also want to increase the
space between
that h2 and the list slash image
components so that was in
section three so the section three h2
and we're just going to make it so that
the margin dash bottom
is five percent refresh and boom
there's a little bit more space there
[Music]
and so this is what we have now super
simple
super just clean
oh and actually i'm realizing i actually
made two changes off screen that i'm
going to fix
that i'm going to show you here i
changed the
line the font weight
of that sub header
that we saw so i had made
the font dash wage to be lighter in
dot right dash text h4 so the
h4 in the right dash text div
i just added font dash weight lighter
and i actually did a similar thing to
this second title
and i changed the font weight there as
well
so in dot section dash three h2
i made the font dash weight 200.
and so not as thin as lighter
but not as thick as just the regular
text we see
and so now everything should look
[Music]
updated
you